et pierre emmanuel thomann consultant
géopolitique et fondateur de oro
continent 1 nous a rejoint
pierre-emmanuel thomann merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pour commencer à propos de ce sommet
entre européens et chinois
peut-on parler d'un contexte très tendu
oui bien sûr c'est un contexte
géopolitique très tendue dans le monde
parce que on a observé qu'avec la
pandémie la rivalité systémique entre la
chine et les états unis s'est renforcée
c'était une c'était déjà une réalité
avant la pandémie
et c'est cette rivalité géopolitique
s'est accélérée et l'union européenne se
trouve en réalité sur le théâtre de
confrontations américano-chinois si elle
ne fait pas bien attention et si elle ne
ne cherche pas à avoir une stratégie
géopolitique qui lui permet d'avoir une
position plus autonome alors on va
revenir à cette position en plus
autonome de l'ordre justement mais
qu'elle était de part et d'autre les
principaux sujets à éclaircir ce matin
pour aborder sereinement la question
d'un accord ou alors il ya il ya le
l'accord en particulier sur les la
protection des investissements mais en
réalité il ya beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels l'union européenne et la chine
dialogue alors sur la la sécurité des
investissements évidemment la difficulté
c'est que la chine est une puissance une
puissance économique et géopolitique et
qui pratique qui a des mesures
discriminatoires qui qui veut poursuivre
c'est exact exportations vers l'union
européenne il faut il faut préciser que
l'allemagne a une relation très étroite
commercial avec la chine et est en même
temps la chine
protège son marché intérieur il n'y a
pas de réciprocité il ya aussi des
transferts de technologies qui sont
exigés des entreprises européennes qui
investissent en chine et il y à des
subventions de l'état chinois aux
entreprises et l'union européenne est en
fête et est en difficulté pour négocier
avec la chine
parce qu'elle a remarqué qu'avec la
pandémie elle était dépendante sur
certains secteurs de l'industrie chinois
il ya eu un phénomène de
désindustrialisation et de relaxe
relocalisation en chine
mais l'union européenne n'a pas les clés
pour négocier elle n'a pas de position
de paradis qui lui permettent d'être en
situation de rapport de force
parce que l'union européenne est basée
sur le paradigme de la société ouverte
du libre échange de la moindre
intervention de l'état dans l'économie
évidemment la chine à d'autres
paradigmes et l'union européenne je
dirais est en retard par rapport à la
nouvelle situation géopolitique mondiale
de rivalité entre grandes puissances et
les l'union européenne est encore
toujours sept anciens paradigmes de deux
sociétés ouvertes de moindre
intervention dans l'économie par exemple
l'union européenne ne protège pas ses
entreprises ne pourraient le
protectionnisme c'est une infamie c'est
un gros mot il n'y a pas de préférence
européenne alors que les chinois
pratiquent la préférence chinoise alors
que l'union européenne est en difficulté
alors du coup à quel type d'accord peut
espérer l'europe
alors je je doute déjà qu'on arrive à un
accord vraiment important entre la chine
et l'union européenne dans le dans un
temps aussi court
de toute façon la chine et l'union
européenne entre dans une relation
difficile qui va être la nouvelle norme
ce qui est le cas entre toutes les
puissances dans le monde parce que d'un
côté comme je les dis les etats unis
font pression sur l'union européenne
pour que l'union européenne s'aligne sur
les états unis pour faire de la chine un
nouvel ennemi
et donc les états unis prennent en
pincent le continent eurasien avec d'un
côté le front oriental contre la russie
et de l'autre côté le la stratégie indo
pacifique contre la chine et l'union
européenne qui considère que les états
unis sont son partenaire principal qui
est complémentaire de l'otan évidemment
penche du côté des états unis mais elle
a une position ambiguë parce que d'un
côté sous la pression des états unis
elle affirme que c'est un rival
systémiques et en même temps elle veut
sauver sa relation commerciale avec la
chine parce que je les dis l'union
européenne la chine est le premier
partenaire du pour la chine c'est
l'union européenne l'allemagne a2 une
relation très forte avec la chine mais
mode qui dépasse aujourd'hui tous les
autres états membres de l'union
européenne et est donc l'union
européenne aimerait jouer sur deux
tableaux mais ce n'est pas possible et
je pense que l'union européenne rate une
opportunité pour l'instant stratégiques
c'est-à-dire un rapprochement avec la
russie
la russie va adopter une position de
relative neutralité dans cette rivalité
géopolitique systémique entre les
etats-unis et la chine et l'union
européenne pour peser dans le débat
aurait intérêt à avoir une position de
non alignement beaucoup plus claire
entre chine etats unis en se rapprochant
de la russie et la russie est demandeuse
de d'une telle posture de non-alignement
et on voit que le l'union européenne
poursuit son approche sur des paradigmes
anciens d'avant la pandémie et n'a pas
vraiment de stratégie de souveraineté ni
de stratégie géopolitique
malheureusement et les états membres
puissent sont divisés parce que
l'allemagne veut sauver en fait sa
relation commercer avec la chine n'a pas
vraiment l'intention de relocaliser
beaucoup d'activité par rapport à la
chine la france a des grands territoires
évidemment dans le pacifique des zones
économiques exclusives mais aussi les
des îles du pacifique et donc a tendance
à plutôt coopérer avec les états unis
dans un endiguement de la chine
vis-à-vis de la stratégie adoptée ci fit
donc
l'union européenne va avoir du mal à se
positionner
merci merci beaucoup pierre emmanuel
thomann d'avoir partagé votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
géopolitique et fondateur d'euro
continent